i
[Música]
ah
colombia es uno de los países más
peligrosos del mundo para los activistas
ambientales en 2020 fue el país con más
asesinatos a líderes ecologistas en lo
que llevamos de año al menos a dos de
ellos se les ha arrebatado la vida la
principal razón por la que se llevan a
cabo estos crímenes suele ser su lucha
contra los proyectos industriales en sus
tierras
varias organizaciones acusan la
vulnerabilidad de estas personas debido
a la falta de protección gubernamental
con esta y otras reivindicaciones más de
230 organizaciones ambientales
convocaron una manifestación el 5 de
junio ya que la violencia y los
asesinatos contra sus líderes han
aumentado durante la pandemia en muchas
ocasiones los líderes indígenas son a su
vez líderes ambientales ya que también
luchan contra la deforestación y la
pérdida de tierra según global forest
watch colombia es el sexto país del
mundo con más deforestación
[Música]
la unión europea a través de sus países
miembros en honduras francia españa y
alemania se han sumado a la lista de
naciones organizaciones nacionales e
internacionales que se mantienen
vigilantes en el juicio que se lleva a
cabo aquí en los tribunales de
tegucigalpa en contra de david castillo
presunto autor intelectual del asesinato
de la líder ambientalista berta cáceres
castillo era el gerente ejecutivo de la
empresa desarrollos energéticos
encargada de la construcción de la
represa agua zarca sobre el río walk
archer proyecto al que berta cáceres
junto a las organizaciones que lideraban
se opusieron férreamente según la ong
global witness desde el asesinato de
berta cáceres el 2 de marzo del 2016 al
menos 40 ambientalistas han sido
asesinados en honduras considerado uno
de los cinco países más mortíferos para
quienes se oponen a los proyectos
extractivistas ya fueron condenados por
esta corte suprema de justicia
y siete responsables autores materiales
del crimen de la reconocida
ambientalista
[Música]
en perú la pandemia del cobe 19 no fue
obstáculo para que líderes indígenas y
ambientalistas sean asesinados se
calcula que al menos 12 de ellos
perecieron porque quedaron vulnerables
al narcotráfico la minería ilegal y la
tabla de árboles el repliegue del estado
peruano y el distanciamiento social
debido a la pandemia los dejo
desprotegidos a ellos sus familias y
comunidades enteras en territorios
ancestrales algunos expertos calculan
que en los últimos dos años alrededor de
100 personas solicitaron protección a
las autoridades por ser represores de
derechos ambientales indígenas y humanos
ante esta situación recientemente el
gobierno peruano instaló la primera red
de alerta rápida para la protección de
líderes indígenas frente a amenazas y
agresiones en contra de su integridad
física y su vida
el mecanismo multisectorial cuenta con
la participación de dirigentes indígenas
funcionarios de estado representantes de
gobiernos regionales y locales
la visión es proteger a los pueblos
originarios y que las agresiones y
crímenes no queden impunes
[Música]